نذهب لمدير مكتبنا في رام الله وليد
العمري بهذه الفكره الضغوط الغربيه كما
قال المسؤول الاسرائيلي كفيله بتقليله
اهميه هذا الاتفاق بين طهران والرياض من
خلال هذا التصريح ربما نفهم الموقف
الاسرائيلي
الفرقاء في اسرائيل يجمعون على ان هذا
الاتفاق يجسد فشلا ذريعا وخطيرا
للحكومه الاسرائيليه وسياسيتها الخارجيه
لكن هؤلاء الفرقاء وهم فريقان الفريق
الاول والذي ينتمي اليه المسؤول الكبير
الذي اشرت اليه وهو من يمين نتنياهو الذي
اجرى احاطه للصحفيين الاسرائيليين
المرافقين له في زيارته الى روما القى
بالمسؤوليه على الحكومه السابقه حكومه
لبيد وبنت واتهمها بان العمل لانجاز هذا
الاتفاق تم في عهدها ولم تفعل شيئا لمنعه
وقال بانه اذا كان هناك تحرك غربي او ثقه
الغربي فممكن ابطاء هذا الاتفاق او تعطيله
لكن هذا واضح بانه غير دقيق نتنياهو حسب
معارضيه يحاول التهرب من المسؤوليه وهو ما
جاء في تعقيبات رئيس الحكومه السابق
ذلك رئيس الحكومه الذي سبقه نفتالي بنت
ووزير الدفاع ايضا ميني غاز جميعهم القوا
باللائمه والمسؤوليه وحملوها الى نتنياهو
وحكومته الحاليه وقالوا هذا يشكل فشلا
ذريعا لحكومته وسياسته الخارجيه لانها
انشغلت بالاساس في مساله في قضاياه
الشخصيه وايضا في الانقلاب على السلطه
القضائيه لماذا يرى هؤلاء ان هذا فشلان
هذا ما عكسته ايضا تحليلات كبار المحللين
في اسرائيل الذين اشاروا الى ان الاتفاق
بين السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه قد بددد
حلم اسرائيل باقامه تحالف اقليمي مهما كان
يسميها نتنياهو بالدول السنيه المعتدله ضد
ايران هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى بانه
يشير الى تراجع عن نفوذ الامريكي لصالح
النفوس الصيني في المنطقه وذهب احد
المحللين كبير المح الحقيقه في صحيفه
يدعوت احنوت على موقعها الى وصف الاتفاق
بانه بمثابه بسقه سعوديه في وجه نتنياهو
وحكومته وذلك لانه عكس انعدام الثقه
السعوديه بقياده الولايات المتحده للعالم
من ناحيه وكذلك انعدام الثقه السعوديه
بمشروع نتنياهو الذي روج له وهو عزل ايران
ومحاوله الحد من مشروعها النووي اضف الى
ذلك ان القراءه في اسرائيل وتصريحات
المسؤولين تخشى من ان الاتفاق من شانه ان
يحيي من جديد الاتصالات من اجل ابرام
الاتفاق النووي لصالح ايران هذه المره
وايضا بانه قد يعيدها الى الى كما وصفها
احد المعلقين الى اعاده تركيب الخريطه
السياسيه للاقليم للمنطقه وذلك وفق
مصالحها ليست الامريكيه بحته مثل ما كان
جاري في المرات السابقه في جميع الاحوال
يرون بانه ايضا من شانه ان يبطئ عمليه او
ما كان نتنياهو يروج له وهو محاوله ان
يعقد مع السعوديه او ضم السعوديه لاتفاقات
ابرهام مثل ما كان يروج نتنياهو منذ
اللحظه الاولى وخلال كل سنه حكمها السابقه
بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال الى ان الاتفاق
اثار هذا الجدل وعلى الصياح بين قطبي
الحكومه والمعارضه في اسرائيل الذي تؤكد
على انهم مقتنعين الخاسر الاكبر من هذا
الاتفاق